many travelers are unhappy with the way
airlines have handled the coronavirus
crisis the Department of Transportation
received more than 25-thousand
complaints from passengers in March and
April it usually receives about 1500
complaints a month a lack of federal
guidelines about how to keep passengers
safe is also causing confusion Kris Van
Cleave talked with two airline CEOs to
see what they are doing online outrage
from fliers as pictures post of
seemingly packed flights a handful a day
leaving up to 85 percent full and at
Charlotte's Airport a steady stream of
fliers Wednesday while the number of
daily travelers roughly doubled from a
month ago on average planes are
departing with just 31 passengers has
people's sense of what crowd it is
changed you know a month or so before
masks were required for employees or
passengers
social distancing was definitely
necessary frontier CEO Barry Biffle is
in Florida encouraging people to get
back to flying his carrier is blocking
20 seats per flight as part of what he
calls a multi-layered approach to safety
that includes electrostatic fogging of
planes to kill the virus and requiring
masks for all aboard so how do you make
people wear a mask so we make it very
clear when you check in whether the
online or in person that you must wear a
facial covering of some type and if you
don't have it we will deny your boarding
what happens if I will refuse to wear
the mask once I'm on the plane but we do
require you to wear a mask and and what
customers are telling us is there feel
safer when everyone's wearing it so it's
not just about you unlike other forms of
mass transit modern airliners typically
have hospital-grade
air filters to strip out virus and
bacteria fresh air is cycled into the
cabin every two to four minutes but
there is no government standard or
guidelines for distancing on a plane it
feels a bit like trial by error right
now this is a unique set of events and I
would say
we are trying to respond as quickly as
we can to something that we've never
seen before and you know our priority is
to make people feel that flying is safe
Robin Hayes runs JetBlue his carrier is
blocking up to 40% of the seats on its
flights can people safely social
distance on an airplane is that a
realistic expectation that's why we're
asking all about customers to wear masks
because you know when you're in a
airline seat giveme of you're keeping
the middle seat free you're not going to
be six feet away from someone should
there be some standardization we would
welcome that
for example we believe you're safe if
everyone wears masks but there's some
inconsistencies with the mass so it
would be great if it was mandated by the
government that everyone wear it just
like you can't smoke on a plane also
making news this morning five Democratic
senators have proposed legislation that
would require Airlines to offer cash
refunds to any flyer who cancelled a
flight for any reason during the
pandemic typically airlines would give
credit for a non-refundable flight they
would have to give a cash refund if this
became law airlines are losing about
seven billion dollars a month and say
this could put them right into
bankruptcy Anthony that's a lot of money
Chris thank you very much